when you guys signed on when you when
you finally got the the roles what did
jeb tell you in terms of like the arc of
your characters and what he's
envisioning because the thing about
vikings is anyone can be killed off at
any time that's true but
because well speaking for me is as
harold hardrada
he's he's got a couple of years left in
him and it's this is sort of an origin
story for this great viking warrior
so
yeah i know that there's a lot to play
with
and one of the amazing things about jeb
stewart and his skills is
he's he's got a a big story arc in his
head and he's able to reference things
important moments in season one that
that have an influence on moments in
season two so so these arcs are big
things and and he was very generous in
taking us in on that on that journey for
sure yeah i i had lots of amazing chats
with jeb stewart our showrunner and like
uh we ended up going quite personally
and speaking about our family and you
know our intentions in our art and
i think
i mean his cv is pretty incredible with
die hard and the fugitive and
we spoke a lot about the iconic
characters in cinema history we're
speaking about clint eastwood with
speaking about robert redford actually
in particular to our relationship with
speaking about butch cassidy and
sundance
um especially as our relationship gets
closer harold leif and
harold's
and then um yeah diving into all the
histories but bringing it back to the um
to the human aspects of a man just
trying to find his way in the world what
is it like for the two of you when
you're reading the scripts and you see
this london bridge sequence and
attacking london are you like get the f
out of here how are we going to do this
you know what i mean
that was an amazing sequence um one of
the joys of it was they built this huge
realistic london bridge in the back of
our studio which we had to play around
in
um and we're
getting up to
crafty business underneath and then we
would go film other scenes in a field
and realize that they built another
london bridge in a field so that the
scale of this thing was was epic and it
and it involved everyone it was a it was
a huge action sequence that every actor
every um performer had their own role to
play within it but as well the coming
together of cgi and
and and all the little pieces of a
puzzle it's it's special to watch i
really enjoyed watching that that moment
for sure yeah no i'd second that i mean
it was cool like we were playing in this
uh this bridge that was built in the
backlight and then
there was three and a half bridges built
for this sequence and um yeah it's just
the perfect uh example of
alchemy and it takes a village to create
such an epic um moment in in on a show
you know it was really really incredible
to see
yeah it all it's like a movie scale
sequence on a tv show and when i spoke
to jeb about it it's like i couldn't
believe you pulled it off with the
budget you know what i mean like this
isn't you guys don't have like a marvel
movie budget yeah i mean i think the
other cool thing about it is it's it's a
battle but it's a battle scene in a
really unconventional sense the strategy
behind this this move in terms of taking
england taking london
it's not just two armies meeting each
other it's
it's complicated in it and it hinges
upon perfect moments perfect timing so
there are really crucial insert shots of
moments when
arrows land or ropes are tied and
bringing that all together is i think
one of jeb's great talents many great
talents
uh completely for for soon to be fans
for both of you what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
actual making of the show like the
behind the scenes they might not know
uh that like
it's such
like we had such a family like a lot of
the crew was from the original series
and so we were kind of like the newbies
coming into this already like
beautifully found family
and like
you know whether it be
you know
hiking up 20 like going for a 25 minute
hike up to an incredible mountain we'd
be carrying some of the costume stuff
the costume people will be carrying some
of the camera stuff like it was a really
like
family-based creation and it was um yeah
it was cool to be just a part of it
yeah i would say because we film in this
beautiful part of ireland but mostly in
this in this one sort of valley it's got
a lake it's got cliffs it's got ravines
and for me i'm struck by
how
diverse a landscape it is and it serves
our show so well with different
locations we use it so much but i think
for the viewers that they'll be
surprised that
that it's technically all the same all
the same place
sorry and it was also a gift to be
welcomed on the collaborative experience
like i was able to design the tattoos
for the character i spoke a bit about
being a vegan and and later on the head
of costume made a vegan armor for me
which was really incredible
um and then uh along with jeb speaking
to us constantly about you know where we
see our characters unfolding and you
know this is very much like like leo
said the origin stories of these
characters and how they acquire the
tools to become
the so-called
the legends that they're known to be uh
last thing for you because i'm basically
out of time it's weird because season
one's about to come out but you guys
have already filmed season two so i'm
just going to ask is there anything you
want to tease for people that are going
to finish the eight episodes in like a
day
i mean it's uh
you know we see
quite an eruption at the end of um
season one
of this held energy this quite violent
energy which he associates to his father
and that kind of kind of comes out and
season two is whether or not he can
control that
if he if he um allows that to take take
over him or whether he takes it back
down and comes to who he feels he needs
to be in this world and for harold you
end the season and he's in bad shape so
he's
he's he's lost a lot so season two
you're gonna discover
what happens next that's not a good
teaser but yeah
i love it and i really hope you guys can
do a season three thank you so much
thank you have a fantastic day thank you
you